1 2 3 4 5 6 7 can you talk zxy w v u TSR
q p o m NL k j i c to do c a cuz no one
else can okay I'll learn it one day we
have four pages of things we want to ask
you I want you to ask me anything that
that you thought perhaps was um maybe
half explained on the documentary
anything that you think people might be
curious about cuz obviously you know me
so well I think you're going to be very
interested in the questions we ask we
get very now yeah we are if you guys
haven't already guessed by his iconic
voice we wrote a little introduction for
you so did you really we did okay today
we have an extremely special episode for
you guys not only are we bringing back a
highly requested guest but this guest is
also giving us an exclusive in-depth
interview about his new Netflix
documentary that came out on November
3rd if you haven't already guessed it
sitting here with us today is none other
than our dad Sylvester
Stallone studio audience and the studio
audience is just Jennifer Stallone
sitting in the background is she
flapping around she's flppy she is
Floppy Bird right now my good luck charm
this is just so surreal by the way thank
you so much for doing this and coming on
our show I know that sounds kind of
cheesy but you know of course girl
apprciate I think I find this to be
quite interesting
because the documentary turned out to be
somewhat of a surprise yeah because I
cannot take credit for anything other
than just answering the questions that
the director asked right and as honestly
as I could and what was so interesting
is you know you're going to do an
interview and I've certainly have done a
lot you sort of prepare yourself but
what was so unique is that be walking
down the hall and he start asking
questions and there's no makeup no hair
anything you're just going to get a
coffee and like what anyone would
normally do you start talking and you
become
completely
unselfconscious because you're like this
you're like this as opposed to oh my God
I have to sit in the chair and I have to
look this way and the questions are more
formal he was very brilliant Tom his
name was Tom is zimy and I gave him all
the credit he did an incredible job I
mean s and I've watched it a couple
times and even now we still are affected
by it and we did read the headlines and
it was alternatively Illuminating and
evasive another called it reflective and
vulnerable and I feel like a lot of
times in your career with a lot of the
things you put out there the reviews are
very polarizing it can either go one way
or the other way so how did it feel
hearing such positive reviews back on
something that is very personal to you
well obviously is somewhat of a shock
because it's not often I get gratifying
reviews and I
think it was also a little frustrating
because I thought God you would think
after 50 years people would know you and
then I realized perhaps I really haven't
shown a lot of myself in cinema of who I
really am well to their point Sophia and
I watched the documentary several times
and to be quite honest there was a lot
of things in this documentary that we
were shocked to find out about you and
I've known you for about 25 years so I
thought I knew everything about you but
it really did
show a great insight into your brain of
why you do the things you do why you
wrote the lines you wrote what your
feelings were in certain scenes and
that's what I think people weren't
understanding before and I guess kind of
the big question is why now why make a
documentary now people people already
know your rags to richest stories how
you started where you became so why now
at your age did you feel the need I
actually want to share this with people
that's a good question because I didn't
feel this overwhelming impulse matter of
fact it was something that I I shied
away from because I thought everyone
does know pretty much if they don't know
me by now I must have done a thousand
television
interviews but the I said the one thing
I haven't done
and a lot of actors don't is why you are
the way you areh why do I gravitate
towards a certain character as opposed
to that other one that would perhaps be
more popular what Dark Side pulls you in
and then what other side the bright side
which is the rocky side so it was kind
of an exploration that I didn't want to
take because I sort of knew the answer
and it all starts when you're very young
when you're a child
and and I I think I said it in the
documentary
that people don't realize how
impressionable and vulnerable when
you're young you
are like I said soft clay mhm and I grew
up in a really bad household it it it
was tough I I don't want to sit there
and cause you know throw aspersions and
this and that but it was not a household
everyone was extremely unhappy with who
they were right I mean and my mother and
father they certainly weren't parents no
words they they said oh I can't wait to
raise a happy normal family when both of
them were completely discontent with who
they were and you think okay is this
what it's really like because girls I
believe it or not I spent spent the
first 4 and a half 5 years in a boarding
house mhm in Jackson Heights and for a
lot of people that don't know what a
boarding house is it's basically a
couple of bedrooms and and run by an
older woman and it's a not a flop house
but it's transient salesman coming in
stewardesses people that are on the move
and I'd sit at this table with adults
and I'm four years
old and no one talked to me and I just
look around and I'm going I have no one
to really relate to and then the next
day they'd be gone and it'd be another
stranger and another stranger and I
think it truly affected the way I
interacted with people I was kind of a a
loner because of that reason well there
was a very interesting point that you
made in your documentary that I don't
think a lot of people picked up on but I
did you had said that your mom was
nervous to have you she didn't want you
right and I thought to myself you quite
literally came into the world
unwanted and your first experience of
life was you felt this negative energy I
don't want this kid he you know your dad
wasn't excited your mom wasn't excited
did you ever as a child feel that at any
moment when you cognizant enough to
understand oh wow I I actually don't
feel loved feel anything it's odd
because the ear s are there I I'm I'm a
little hesitant but too
incredibly uh repetitive because it was
told to me so many times my mother would
say the only reason you're here is
because the hanger didn't
work or bouncing down those steps didn't
cause you to get
lost and she said that you know
truthfully Sylvester and believe it or
not they called me
Binky because there was a hairbrush
called the binky brush and for some
reason said Binky you know if there was
really something wrong with your brain I
would have definitely open up the window
and put you on the window so and let you
freeze because I'd be doing you a
favor it you know your brain is too
young to computer I almost thought she
was joking yeah of course yeah I mean
what type of mother says that to their
child I mean that's actually something
I've we've been questioning when we were
watching the documentaries between us we
all know you know the the abuse you went
through with your mother but you and we
definitely want to dive into your
father's psyche and like the why he did
the things he did to you and how it
affected your you know creative process
and your future but what was the
decision of leaving your mother out when
she had just as much impact on your
upbringing as he he did I thought it
would be too much for the audience I
thought that they would say ah he's
making this up or perhaps he's looking
for
sympathy because it was it it's you know
when you're young you're kind of naive
and foolish go maybe everyone's mother
is like this right I never really hung
out with other people so I didn't know
what a happy home was I thought this
is normal you know modus operandi right
but as I got older I realized there was
uh some critically bad behavior going on
and then as I got older I realized
perhaps they are just um a product of
their yeah which wasn't necessarily so
but I kept thinking oh maybe
they're but my mother was
um
h
she was
a she was a troubled person she was uh
put into an orphanage you know and um a
very cruel orphanage because her father
had remarried and the new stepmother
hated her MH and I think my mother was
also kind of rebellious so she was put
into a an orphanage that it's unlike the
ones they have today it was you know
you're tied to the bed you're whipped
and you're she was terribly molested wow
and I think her ability to ever show
love
was short circuited she literally
couldn't stand to be touched or
touch at all I mean not even hug so as a
child though yeah touches the most
important thing you can give a kid so
how did her lack of touch towards you
skin on skin contact affect you long
term I mean did it affect the way that
you view meaningful relationships or
developing even friendships with people
how did their lack of being available to
you carry with you long term I I um well
I could tell you could ask my wife I
didn't like being touched I I couldn't
handle it I you know any sort of
affection touch like this it was so
alien that it made me incredibly
uncomfortable and I've just literally
come to terms with with of course your
mother which I love now but she'll tell
you for years right um I just thought
that was normal yeah you remember just
holidays alone how uncomfortable growing
up it made you I mean you had to truly
relearn how to have a healthy
relationship ship when Mom came into the
picture and having a family because you
weren't used to you know yeah do you
remember I didn't like Christmas I like
board
games actually in Rocky that's what I
wrote one of the lines where Adrian
comes out he goes what is a special day
it's Thanksgiving I said to you to me
it's Thursday right and that's the way
that's true true well I to me what I
think a lot of people loved throughout
this documentary is how
many hidden messages
you explained that were in your dialogue
for example one of my favorite ones and
I had no idea okay was when Mickey comes
to your door yeah and you did a take and
then you did another take and that
second take was really what you wanted
to say to your dad right but you never
did no why didn't you I didn't have the
guts I I don't I I was afraid of them
and I don't think I was articulate
enough and um when I wrote the
screenplay that didn't exist and then I
said there's something I I got to do
something to to explain the frustration
of wanting to say this but you can't say
it but you can say it to a door but when
the man's face is in front of you just
frze up and cuz I was I was afraid of
them course there was no joke there was
no joke and I thought my God this is so
great that I got a chance to do this in
Rocky I what I couldn't do in reality
that was pretty much a very a
biographical moment so when all of this
was going on and a lot of people I think
can experience you know they've had
situations with their parents where
abuse was happening growing up what kind
of survival tactics did you do to kind
of you know survive the day I feel like
when you're alone survival yeah I didn't
it wasn't as though I had okay here's
plan a plan B I was so caught up in
unreality non-reality fiction I I never
went to school and I would always uh
kind of identify with cartoon figures
mythical Superman Batman this man you
name it it got to the point that I
actually would sometimes make these
horrible costumes out of a Barber's cape
and pair of bathing suit and go to
school Under the clo
I would be I'd feel like I'm the real
character they don't know that oh yeah I
know all right until I got busted and
then it was pretty embarrassing like oh
we have a special guest here today oh
super boy would you like to step up and
I take off my shirt and my bony legs and
oh my God would you like to fly around
the room for us I go then they back then
they had a thing called the dunce cap oh
gosh oh yeah it actually existed I know
we SE in cartoons I you know you have
the D oh yeah as super boy oh no my God
but that that completely makes sense for
your childhood to be doing things like
that you're you're longing so hard for
an idol or a role model or someone to
look up to so but you wanted to be that
so you oh my God because I'm sorry my
nose is running um what I wanted to do
is just find something that would make
me heroic for some reason I always
wanted to Garner some sympathy or
something and and because I wasn't
getting it at home and I then I became
sort of a thief right because I would
whatever I could find for example in my
father's pocket to be like five or six
bucks believe it or not it was kind of
dangerous I would take the money let it
be five ones or quarters or whatever and
go to school and give it to people like
you want to be my friend stop that
sounds like something s us to do growing
up what pay for friendship well used to
give people goldfish didn't pay people
for friend she used to give people
goldfish friendship for sale friend well
it seems it seems like a lot of the
things that went it from your parents
abuse than the way that they treated you
growing up well it garnered a lot of
attention and seeking that and then also
do you think a lot of the deep wounds
that you got from them created this
creative obsessionist that you developed
now like you were always looking at
Movies always writing always trying to
be the hero you know as an escapism oh
for sure there was a I spent hours that
sounds so sick but there was a really
cheap in my mother's bedroom three-way
kind of mirror you know you get it in
you can see all sides and if you get in
there you see like 2500 figures in so MH
I would spend hours in that thing
because you're moving around go look how
many friends I have and look at like and
you constantly entertain yourself for
hours as opposed to playing sports or
this and that yeah and it and it now I
look at it that's that wasn't a very
healthy thing but
truthfully I also look at it as this is
a preface it or a a
prelog to where I was going to go I felt
so comfortable in this kind of fake
World imitating s s and this and that
that that was my reality and stepping
outside that mirror it was D I don't I
don't feel comfortable at all cuz I
didn't hang out with people I didn't
play sports really I didn't uh I was a
troublemaker I got into a lot of
altercations because I was so odd but I
I never had a like a team let's go play
baseball and whatever and no never but
that mirror in that area that kind of
fantasy world provided unlimited
entertainment for me and escapism well
that makes sense because you're not
getting attention from anywhere else
makes sense I think it's crazy no but
understanding how you grew up and what
you went through you just wanted
entertainment you wanted attention and
so who was going to give it to you no
one you make it for yourself and I that
makes sense to why you got kicked out of
14 Schools while you getting fight don't
get carried away so sorry you guys 13 my
mistake or while into fights with people
because it really was just this longing
for attention and that definitely showed
throughout the documentary when you were
explaining how you know you wanted
attention from the public so you'd go to
the theaters you look up at the screen
and all these people are watching that
one guy and you wanted to be that guy I
don't know if I was that early on though
I knew that growing to films I was
looking for definitely a male role model
right yeah 100% and those role models
were never really what I call good
actors they would be not even Cowboys it
would be always mythical figures
Hercules the seventh Voyage of sined
Jason in the organized you know what I
mean fantasy dealing with creatures so
mythology has been my go-to fantasy my
whole life matter of fact I I believe
that my entire career is based on that
mhm was Rambo was mythological so Rambo
is kind of like what what a kind of
weird hero but he he he was almost a
superhero in times because how could he
survive these battles he has no skill
he's a terrible fighter he's this and
that but there was just something that
propelled him and that's my fantasy like
people always Rising above their
abilities right well that's actually
funny cuz sine and I we equally agreed
on this and we said you said that we we
were like there's this type of and this
is not a take to take offense to it but
you had this delusion that you were
going to be that hero you are that hero
or you watched those guys as as they
were like the who was it Chris Reeves
that Steve re Steve Reeves that you saw
as the iconic throws the breaks the
chains gets out is the hero everything
but the delusion was so strong that you
came from nothing you had no support no
money no education but yet you still
said there will be nothing that will
stand in my way of being that guy on the
screen being the star how did you even
continue that delusion because you know
eventually some people are saying well
that's a dream it's going to die it's
not going to be because we're talking
about the fact that you went to New York
and you you know were knocking on every
single door people were rejecting you
you would try to go on stage and maybe
you get a role in something but bar
anything you would create all these
films but you you would keep writing and
and you would just get no no no no but a
lot of people most people end it there
but you didn't no then what was it
that's a very that's that's real
conundrum
because I didn't I just thought it was
impossible for me to do anything that
would be just
considered regular normal I just didn't
think I had the brain for it or the
discipline oh and I and I had such a
kind of fixation on doing something
heroic or special like I thought oh I
want to be a great
coach I got to be I never played a sport
in my life so it's like that and then I
thought oh I'm I'd like to be a great
horse trainer I didn't have any horses
but I always looked I so I cannot do
anything normal and it bothered me it
really bothered me I I would be so add
and so consumed with daydreaming okay
and I mean bad daydreaming L where I
would be sitting there and in the class
and I don't know I don't remember I went
to three and a half years of college I
don't remember one day well neither do I
no I'm serious I I went to the ring
theater and tried to do some acting and
they go you really don't have it but why
don't you learn to work backstage like
moving furniture and I did it was it but
I I'll tell you girls I found those
those important rejections and failures
to be the best thing that ever happened
because it forces you to either quit or
say you know maybe they're right I want
to try another Direction maybe I'm not
that good an actor and perhaps I wasn't
but I want to be in the business who
I'll try to write yeah right and I was
terrible terrible right I don't think I
ever
passed an English course in my life ever
ever but I kind of had a feeling
of what people would like in stories
which is like hope right happiness
overcoming it's kind of a a mythological
thing it's like the hero comes through
and right and I thought that I can
relate to as opposed to Too Much realism
I hated realism I hated because the
reality is realism is said yeah I I want
to get in I really want to get into your
writing but what we're talking about
right now there's a big Trend going
around and it's sounding like you
originated this trend it's called what
is it main character of your life
basically this is going around with our
generation and people are saying you
want to be the main character of your
life so everything you do you do with
confidence you do it nothing can stop
you no one's going to stand in your way
and you basically were the OG of owning
your own destiny and and believing it
and I think you know your goal and where
you ended up is incredible story but for
the average person being a Hollywood
star is somewhat unobtainable so what
advice would you give to that person
that doesn't feel like they can do it
isn't confident enough to finish it or
just something to help them not
quit um I don't I I
couldn't believe I said why would I this
person who doesn't know me is telling me
I'm a failure right yeah who's he right
this person doesn't know me you've met
me for five minutes you know what you're
not right for this part and it triggered
something that what makes
you know me better than I know myself I
and that kind of rejection mhm it you
have it's fight or flight girls you
either say you're a liar or I'm a liar
and I'm going to prove perhaps you're
lying but the truth was I wasn't right
they were right at times but I never
quite gave into it the whole time or if
I failed I'll tell you I remember I went
out for this
part uh it was the only play that
Picasso wrote called desire caught by
the tail it was very bizarre it was all
all his char characters and the part
that I was supposed to play was the
halfman half B so you were supposed to
be a big muscular guy right okay the guy
they hired was this big muscular guy I
mean he was perfect twice my size and I
said to the director I think I can do
this differently than him yeah he goes
we need a big muscular guy I said I I'm
going to pretend I'm a big muscular guy
I'm going to act oh my gosh I got the
part what I got the part because ins it
there was a certain ferocity yeah and
that came from my father is that that I
was just about to ask this question I
finally understood wow I've got
something going on in there that I don't
have a lot of control over but I know
it's different and that's what I was
going to ask I was going to say was this
inherited or was this learned and I feel
like a lot of this actions that you've
made in the beginning was learned but it
was also inherited he this rage in him
and that he he didn't want to get
rejected I mean his whole life he was
and so he said I'm not going to take
this anymore from not my father from
anybody at this point but then it also
was learned I mean you you have to have
this type of you know mentality to
constantly tell yourself that I'm going
to be able to do it I'm going to make it
I'm going to make it so I was going to
ask you if you thought it was inherited
or learned but it seems like it's pretty
much both for you it is both yeah I
think you you have personality then you
have character personality is what you
you know you copy your father you copy
your mother she speaks a certain way oh
you have the same accent that's
personality right character is like
looking into a a play pen of 10 dogs
each one is different it's the same
litter right but there's 10 different
personalities and that's called
character and I'm telling you I never I
never doubted for a second that I didn't
fit in in other words I knew I was
different not counted or whatever but I
said I'm I was always I don't know if I
ever told you but I was shot once in the
arm huh yeah I was shot once it was
weird I went to a mom mom did you know
he was shot she said no hold on this is
breaking news on the unwax podcast small
little scar there what no her eyes are
wide what is going on well I don't tell
you everything honey I mean it's only 36
years we got I got to keep some Secrets
now so what happened is I went to a
church dance I didn't know anyone there
okay but I just saw a dance and I went
in and this is the Story of My Life in a
nutshell for some reason there's a group
of guys over there tough looking guys
I'm alone I don't know anyone in this
dance maybe there's 500 people of all
the 500 people they zero in on me no of
course guy walks over to me a big a
dying guy you're like hey get out of
here and we're going to smack you in the
face qu I'm looking around I didn't do
anything he hits me hard and I went whoa
and I'm telling you I went around I'm
looking around for help there's no one
there and I put my tail between my legs
like a abject coward and I started
walking away and I was probably three or
four blocks away going past this parking
lot and I
stopped I said I can't I I can't live
with is I I cannot live the rest of my
life knowing that some stranger came up
and hit me hard for
nothing so you got to do something and
what go back in go back in so I turned
around oh go I go back in into the
church there's the dance the music is
going I see this guy he's standing was
like he's laugh mocking like oh yeah I
smacked this guy I hope you smacked him
I hope you did I turn around bang I
crack him oh he go oh shoot but he was
so big it barely hurt him and he comes
roaring at me so a priest gets in the
way he hits the priest what oh yeah and
then they all start chasing after me and
I'm jumping over fences they're jumping
over fences they were from actually from
Rocky's neighborhood it was called
kening Full Circle Moment full circle
they were badasses go so I finally made
it to my house yeah and they knew where
I lived and they were waiting and
waiting they we called the cops cops
said well they're not doing they're
every time we come they drive away and
then one night I slipped out and they
followed me and I went going to this
bowling alley and I started running and
pow and I they shot me through the
tricep oh my gosh how old were you 16
and I and I kept going and going and
going and finally after the shot yeah
then the police came and then I said
it's these maniacs and of course they
were gone but they never came back
because they were scared away but can
you imagine so I I real I always had
these moments where for some reason I
was the guy that got into trouble you
know that guy it just non-stop in school
yeah he's the Troublemaker he's that so
you know you sort of stand out that was
the moment a way did you ever get
annoyed
that maybe because of your childhood
upbringing now you have this rage you
sort of became a street Thug guy and
then you started getting cast as only
that role did that ever bother
you yeah it it did because I saw myself
as a funnier person kind humorous I do
jokes I wasn't super social I mean I I
lived in New York for 4 years and never
left my room I never went to a bar a
restaurant a dance New Year's Eve was
that anxiety or was that just no I just
never felt compelled to do it I don't
know why I would write and I would sit
there and watch I this black and white
TV but I just didn't feel like I fit in
like what do I walk into a bar with a
bunch of strangers I know what's going
to happen right cuz it happened again
later on it's another story oh my God in
the 70s it was a bad one of course but
you know what I mean so
yeah I um um I want to talk about Lords
of Flatbush because why because that is
your ultimate cool ass role honestly I
thought you were so cool and seeing you
back then all baby face and a leather
jacket I feel like I can now put a
picture to all of the stories that
you've been telling us over the years
yeah but what I found was so interesting
about the documentar is that was your
first introduction into writing anything
when you began to rewrite your lines and
rewrite them better right do you think
that if you had never spoken up in that
moment and said to the director hey I'm
going to improvise I'm going to rewrite
my lines there ever would be a rocky
because you wouldn't have know because
honestly what if what if you said
nothing and then you wouldn't have had
that confidence to go write a script I
think it was that confidence you're
absolutely right no seriously that
because um it was a very it was an okay
play yeah but my character was just kind
of like a dumbbell right and I thought
he's got to have some sensitivity on the
outside and that's what the way I was
portrayed in real life I'm not really
that way I look it but I also have a
very sensitive side and I thought if I
have this girlfriend and she needs to be
married and I don't want to get married
and then she gets impregnant and I buy
her ring the audience is going to say
yeah he is a bum and a thug but kind
is's he's really nice to the girl there
was something there and I've always
believed that then I realized at that
point that was my goal in life and if I
had never done that to play those kind
of characters I know I was never going
to be like the huge Jackman or this I'm
never going to play the the boyfriend
the lover the I'm always that guy I
remember Woody Allen goes through a
Crowd Goes God who it looks like he
looks like a thug and I was picked out
of like a hundred people to chase Woody
down and beat him up same thing with
Jack Lemon I was always the guy no
matter how much I tried so when I wrote
Rocky I want to write don't judge a book
by her cover leather hat gloves whatever
but inside he's like a sof Fe but he
didn't start out that way and that was
so interesting is when you mentioned in
the the documentary how someone read it
and they CED cuz they said Rocky is a
thug and that's how you viewed yourself
because if Rocky is you you thought you
were the thug you thought that that's
what people saw you as and then the
moment that someone caught it and said
Hey where's the heart that's when Rocky
was born truly okay I'll tell you what
happened is the typist said I hate it
crying he's such a bully he's this and
that and I don't care what people say
you are the product of what come what
came before you in other words
influences this podcast oh there was the
person who did that I like to borrow a
little from that then went so you're
always taking things like Picassa said
you find your own style no one's born
with like oh this genius style they are
the product of many influences yeah good
or bad so this so with the rocky
character I went God you know I'm you
know what I was copying dairo in Mean
Streets who was very mean okay it was
kind of soulless tough guy well it was
probably that was his character see what
I mean right and I went why don't I just
that's really not me I was trying to be
overly New Yorker actory right yeah I
want to be this guy and I I mean I had I
was so nuts I wanted Rocky to look like
all beat up I actually glued my nose D
on my
life I went out and bought coloss bag
glue you know what colomy bag is
no stop well stop why would we know that
okay well some people have trouble
pooping because they haven't intestinal
problems that's great and they put a bag
here oh and
they I know I didn't know what that was
called okay very powerful glue so I
glued my nose cuz it's crooked anyway
it's been broken something like this and
I look so I audition like this and
you're wondering why they were like this
is not going to work I look like such a
Monster killer take the glue off and
perhaps maybe be a little nice you have
a dog
goldfish but no I was like hey I look
terrifying oh gosh my no straight here
you go that's crazy oh I never told you
that yeah no I never knew that no no one
I'm sorry I told everyone and you're
full of M colos face right right right
one of the things I really loved um
about the documentary and it's something
Sophia and I can heavily relate to
Growing Up is your tape recorder and you
recorded everything and as Sophia had
mentioned before forth when you were
describing Rocky as you were listening
back to your digital diary we'll call it
you weren't able to admit that it is a
love story because maybe at the time you
didn't understand or couldn't grasp what
what love was no I didn't was there ever
a moment when you were filming Rocky one
with Adrien and at that point when
you're in that
scene you're not Sly you're Rocky and
she's truly Adrian do you think that was
maybe your first experience of love the
show today is sponsored by better help I
have recently been on my own therapy
journey and I cannot express how much it
has changed my life especially with the
holidays coming up it's the end of the
year lots of family gatherings it can be
a really overwhelming time yeah and I've
been in therapy and I totally understand
where C's coming from I'm really proud
of her for sharing this and I think it's
important to know that you know it's
okay to ask for help and so that is why
we are so excited to be working with
betterhelp because better help is a
super convenient fast affordable way all
online to find a therapist so you take a
test and then they pair you up with a
licensed therapist and the best part is
is if you're not compatible with your
therapist free of charge they can switch
you up and find one that's more suited
for you so if you want in on this
amazing deal we are giving you guys
visit betterhelp.com
unwaxed for 10% off your first month
that is better
hp.com unwaxed for 10% off find the
brightness in your holiday season ho ho
ho I I can't honestly say
that I ever went into it as a love story
okay I thought he loved this woman but I
still saw it as kind of like a fight
film a boxer tough guy masculine movie
that's what I was making and then this
thing happened right which is after it
came out I went oh my God you fool
that's what made this is her right not
the boxing the love yeah and that's
actually what I was going to ask was
like who reation yeah like who was she
to you because if you didn't if you
didn't have any love you created a love
story
unintentionally what was Adrien like
representing in your life she was just
what she represented to me was another
Outcast mhm she was an outcast I an
outcast I related to her originally I
wrote it with not Adrien in mind it was
a different tougher person much harder
individual right almost like a female me
and all those actresses bailed out like
met Sher and B Midler Sher was supposed
to be in Rocky number one choice really
yeah and then P Midler had done the rose
and she was like I thought this' be kind
of interesting she could be Street and
tough and they turn me down too which I
don't blame them I was nobody and
finally then suan Randon turn it down MH
a lot but she I think she was like too
attractive to play the part back then
and then in walks Talia Shire and the
ceiling almost fell on my head what what
was I thinking mhm this is a combination
of everything right and that's what what
are you looking at me like that for no
you know what that's really interesting
that you just said that because you're
the type of person where your instinct
is so good and spoton whenever we do
anything artistic or creative that you
just know so what you just said about
when she walked into the room and the
ceiling almost fell down yeah that's
literally how you described mom when she
walked into the room for the first time
when you just know say the Earth shakes
she ran out of here she's too nervous
it's true no but that's what it is you
just but your your gut is so accurate
which is crazy because because I
sometimes trust my gut I'm saying well
fooled me again that's not correct
because you haven't hit the you haven't
hit the bullseye yet when you hit the
bullseye your body is just going to
shake and it it's l it's it's hard to
describe it almost takes your breath
away this person is so unique I didn't
even ask her to audition not that I
deserve to ask anybody to audition
because she was just perfect right I
said I can't do any better and luckily
it was all the cast was just perfect I
just find it crazy I just thought about
this how you wrote it in 3 days I just
it's so shocking to me that something's
so massive was WR it's not that hard
because how do you not think it's hard
because I'm not a perfectionist a lot of
it was sloppy and useless but I knew I
would get it the second third fourth
fifth 10th time around I think the most
important thing in anything we do not
just writing anybody is just get to the
end zone I don't care how and then you
can fix it second time around so I knew
writing as I'm going just get to the
ending get to the final scene get to the
point where you say I love you I love
you and the scene is over done
movie then you can start to fix it but I
find the majority of people myself
included that you're looking for
procrastination you're looking for
distraction and it takes 10 months to
write a screen plate a year sometimes
you never finish and I've been that that
person too so I tell people I don't care
how bad it is right 10 pages are garbage
but it's 10 pages you actually sat down
and a Cy what would you tell someone
that is really just lagging and they're
taking a while and they're
procrastinating cuz you were the type of
person that went to to the extreme and
blocked out his windows and didn't leave
for 3 days in a row now how do you find
that almost fire in your belly to not
stop and get it done you really want to
know
yes I would call
it kind of like
um miror psychoanalysis mirror
psychoanalysis I'm going to sound like
such a maniac here we can cut it if you
don't like it no I I would find myself
just sitting there
procrastinating and then I would get up
in the mirror and I'd look at myself I
said you know what you are you're a lazy
piece of [__] you're [__] useless I
hate your guts you'd rather sit there
and do nothing you know why cuz you're a
[__] coward and I would tear like I'm
literally fighting myself challenging
humiliating myself interesting I say sit
down I'm going to slap you so hard crush
your face you goddamn coward and it it
became it's like me and my father
talking I was to and I would intimidate
myself I say sit down I don't feel like
it I'll break every bone in your face go
and sit on that goddamn chair and do
what you could do I don't give it [__]
if it's bad get on the table wow and I
mean I was really violent yeah I'm not
joking and this kind of weird analysis
of just intimidation yeah it's kind of
sometimes when you see a coach go
berserk on a player because he knows
that player has it in him but he's just
not digging deep enough and he
humiliates his
guy and then he breaks him and I'm sorry
just it's funny that's what I would do
you know no it's funny because in our
generation a lot of people go into the
daily affirmations I'm I'm I'm a victim
to that but where you talk to yourself
positively and you say all the good
things and it's funny because honestly
it's so true because sometimes when you
get told be gentle on your no you can't
be gentle you got to I'm telling you I'm
a product of intimidation I felt in my
whole I know what intimidation is and I
know what it can do yeah right it'll get
you off your ass trust me you don't want
to hurt yourself you don't want to be
hurt and then you actually are so
embarrassed that you're not performing
I'm let me put it this way I shame
myself into performing interesting but
it gets harder when you get older
because now you start getting successful
you don't feel like beating
yourself so but I still do it at times I
still today oh yeah like if I'm doing a
scene and before Tulsa king or whatever
and I have
to really get it up I I mean I get in
there and I just rip myself to pieces
and I'm when I come out that that
set i'm I look calm but I'm I'm bloating
inside when you are having that
conversation with yourself in the mirror
yeah do you hear your voice speaking to
you or your dad's voice uh
oh welcome to therapy it's not me it's
not you well okay let's let's fast
forward a little bit because we're on
this I shouldn't say it it's my adult me
is I I can't give total owness or blame
someone else because I've heard that
I'm going to blame him sorry well he put
He put the rage in you so it's not like
that's a surprising thing for you to say
it's him but I have mixed feelings about
that too
okay I mean we had
some I used to say to him I wish we were
the same age for 5 minutes he go why
he's probably 65 I said I just would
like to pound your head through a wall
like you did me he
goes my wait do it I'm right here God
he's so manipulative he no but he was so
tough then I started laughing like God
damn that didn't work he just really
could not be intimidated no he he's he's
Stone this guy is Stone so he's the real
deal Rocky's a success you're at the top
of the mountain it's fantastic Rambo
comes into the picture and I always
looked at it like Rocky was your
emotional Rocky is one of the saddest
days in my life why when he came out
because
here we go I should put this in some
book someday I was here a year before I
was destitute I had nothing I was broke
and it came out and a miracle happened
and I'm with some of the best films in
Hollywood I'm like God I'm in the
same category as best picture and these
guys are great writers and great scor
just great people and they gave me a
front row
seat and I invited my
mother and she goes I'm like you want me
to go with you I go I'm up for an Oscar
yesterday I I was a bum a year ago he
goes all right but you have to invite
Vivian I go who's Vivian she go my
hairdresser I don't have a seat for your
hairdresser it's you and me front row
the ask go my gosh if you don't invite
Vivian I'm not
coming I go you haven't seen Vivian in
10 years she lives in Washington DC he
says I want to see Vivian with me and
then I'll
go well she didn't go so us went alone
M I think I invited my brother or
another guy but yeah that was so I have
when people go ah you must have loved
the Oscars they go not so not really
there ever one time and I'm not even
going to say rocky in your
entirety of your acting career that they
ever acknowledged how proud they were of
you no not
once you mean them
yeah no but didn't that kill you cuz I
think as Sophia and I are going through
this right now where we feel our
responsibility as your daughter yeah is
to make our parents proud and that one
day when they're all gone they'll leave
this earth knowing that they raised
incredible kids that did something well
and something that you can look back on
and be happy about and now you
are quite literally flipping what your
world was coming into it and making
something
incredible didn't that kill you for them
to not acknowledge this is a one in a
billion you are what you're doing right
now
I I yeah that that was evident to me but
the difference is girls you were
raised so much differently such a loving
mother my skin was like scar tissue and
other words after a while it it rolls
off your back you know now what did I
expect you know it's you I knew that was
coming you know what I mean you become
imperious immune to it
you expected it it would be shocking if
she said she said proud absolutely I
know it's just the opposite so you get
to the top I was going to ask you what
your moment that you recall that you
knew your life was going to change
completely I don't know if there was
like a specific moment but we can go
past that but you get to the top and now
almost now you're trying to find the
validation or whatever it is through the
critics through the reviews through the
audience and you see that the mountain
cuz you said some sort of of um you said
some sort of I don't know what it was
but analogy about the mountain being
high but it sucks up there or the air
is Lonely at the Top so how was that
pressure you know when you get to the
top you're doing all these films you do
Rocky you do Rambo and you're at the top
and now they're expecting more more more
and then you get fist turns into junk
and stop where my mom will shoot and all
of these other films that kind of Oscar
that were kind of flops how did you you
know maneuver that because now you have
things to lose you know it's a different
type of scenario than it was
before uh I think a lot of
it I maybe brought it on myself I didn't
think about the project enough or
perhaps I was a bit
beligerant and I think I
overcorrected when Rocky hit it was like
see I knew I told you I told you I told
you I proved it is that kind of a thing
yeah which turned a lot of people off
and I get that
but it
never I I don't it never brought me like
real happiness like yeah right I I
didn't actually to this day I it's very
hard to Revel in success I swear to you
if a if a movie like oh yeah first blood
came out it's a big
hit appreciate it and never think about
it again yeah I I know I just it's like
uh are you obsessed with continuing to
push the Box do more bigger cast bigger
explosion more surgery more pain More
Money More reviews more audience like
was was that ever happening because you
know it yeah it is it is but it's in a
different um format for example you say
more injuries during the filming of this
thing you know we're talking about back
injuries I had five
during the filming I had two more so I
have seven from literally just in the
making of
Sly but
truthfully I I I don't seek out any more
Grandeur self grandis what I really want
to do is be I guess a mentor I I would
love to have a production company where
I can bring in young mes or other people
that that were perhaps slighted and say
you know your story is foolish and go
it's not foolish maybe you need to do
this and maybe and I can use all
this hard com by knowledge yeah to build
something and I could say oh carry on
thank you very much I mean I seek that
for you girls I I I seek it for all
young artists I I don't have anything to
prove really you know I think think I do
I mean there's some but vacancies in
there but I want to do something that's
not say oh about me I said here's what
I've learned and I I want you to take it
yeah and use it I can help you with this
I can guide I could be there I say it
parental right I I have to say that's
really refreshing to hear it's true
because I know and I believe you I swear
to you I I believe everything you're
saying there was um there was a time I
want to say in about 2003 and up up
until before this you are the biggest
celebrity in the world everyone knows
your name you have millions of fans
worldwide stop okay no I'm not going to
blow smoke up your butt anymore but you
were what and you have it all you marry
mom yeah you have three daughters you
have a home you have it influx of love
that is coming at you from every angle
and there was a period around I want to
say 20 2003 or 4 where you didn't work
and you couldn't book a job I think
maybe around eight 7 8 years nothing and
what I found so interesting about your
documentary is the amount of parallels
and this particular parallel is one that
the audience doesn't know because we
lived it with you so this is private
knowledge but it's not bad it's I
thought it was fascinating Jennifer no
listen I thought it was fascinating
because it made me understand why you
did what you did MH so for those 8 years
when we were growing up and you weren't
working that killed you yeah and what
you did was you'd go into the movie
theater lock yourself in there MH for 10
12 maybe more hours a day and just watch
film and when you explained in the
beginning of your documentary how when
you were lost you didn't know who you
were you wanted something or someone to
look for some guidance you'd go to the
the movie theater and you'd stay there
all day right and I just thought that
was such an interesting comparison I
said maybe you were doing the same thing
you reverted back to the way you were
when you were a child looking for an
answer yeah I guess you go back we're
half you so no may you go back to that
womb that's what I'm saying I think you
were subconsciously trying to find
yourself again it's the only Solace I
could find I felt so useless really
useless you know you've been to the top
and wow that was a rough time so I can I
you in one
way people say I'm glad it happened no
I'm not glad it happen
but it made me a much better performer
right and and much more sensitive
because I realized this is what life is
this is what people they don't have this
you know happy Hollywood ending right
and it kills me because that's why I
like up endings because life usually
doesn't end that way so why do you have
to go out and spend money and see it and
feel bad because I feel bad enough
walking in here I don't need you to make
it worse that's my simple philosophy it
doesn't exactly go along with true art
but I never said I was going to make
true art yeah and it's ironic that with
that period of not working and being in
the you know the movie theater for so
many hours you came back by writing
Rocky baloa right which was basically
the thing that started you in the first
place so you went back to the first
thing that you got you to the top and
when you're at the bottom again you
brought Rocky back into the picture and
you said it was your most proud work by
far because uh nobody wanted to do it I
I felt so
worthless and I was so embarrassed to be
your father tell you the truth because
you didn't even know what I did
basically for a living we saw your Spy
Kids Toy Maker what does my father do
for a living just wanders around looking
depressed and I realized you you people
that you thought were your friends and
not your friends when the good times go
away that's when you find out your
family is so important cuz I'm telling
you the ship sailed on me it was pretty
bad it was pretty bad but I took all
that in and I thought you
know if this is if I'm done and I
thought I was it was definitely done
phone wasn't ringing it was done and I
was so embarrassed because people did
not understand Rocky 5 Rocky five was
about one of the more real situations
that you're so desperate to not be a
failure for your family that Rocky
basically gave up his family because he
wanted to get Glory again even if it was
through another man that he for you know
his son he gave up wife he was this and
that and I wasn't I was not smart enough
to realize that's not what people wanted
to see because that's what happens right
you know that's a little too real right
and I said if I can just go back and do
one more because I never thought I'd
ever do another movie again but in my
fantasy I want to do Rocky B Bo which is
about loss about grief which is is the
hardest thing in the world to live with
girls I swear to you oh [__] it it's
it's
hard I think anyway yeah I don't know
why all of a sudden get traumatic like
that you know some [__] just comes up
and you I said how can I write a story
that I portray that kind of sad you know
what I mean and but in the end it's you
purge yourself of it and that's what
Rocky Balo is about he loses his wife he
loses everything and people have they
you know they they that's what they
experience but in the end he purges
himself with what he says I want to get
rid of this old pain and put in some new
pain I don't want that those memories
anymore and it worked it really worked
well and uh that's my proudest moment
because
nobody wanted to do it and they actually
said you're done Ro's done I'm going
these are people that represented me
that were like I paid lots of money to
and I went wow you really are yeah on
your own and I want your girls to know
that your best friend has got to be you
I'm serious it's great to have best
friends and parents or whatever but you
then I got and I did that thing I told
you about in the mirror and I sh you
come back you fight you get off your
knees you stop feeling sorry for
yourself and you write the best words
you've ever written and I think it is by
far Rocky one I think has the element of
surprise but Rocky 6 is the best I I I I
can't do any better as I could yeah and
I thought and then it was kind of like
oh that's just another rock God she guys
no I mean I think the way that you wrote
it maybe they did didn't see it the same
because no they didn't that's that's how
you express your emotions is through
storytelling is through writing I mean
you wanted to address something to Mom
you wrote her a love letter like
everything you did was not conventional
but it was through a story right but I
also feel like there was something I
wrote down and I really wanted to ask
you this question because I've seen a
lot of the documentary what you've
mentioned a few times was the word
regret a lot of times in the first first
scene
of your documentary you basically
mention how you know regrets even when
you were broke people you know offered
you money you almost took it but you
didn't want to regret not having that
opportunity I mean when you were not
working for 8 years you didn't want to
regret not putting in the effort to
create this new is regret the driving
force without a doubt it's fear cuz
regret breeds fear or it's like oh my
God I I if I don't do this I'm going to
regret for the rest of my life and I'm
so afraid of that feeling because I know
what it's like cuz you can't fix it you
can't fix yes today you can only fix
tomorrow and so it's one of my that and
Redemption I would say sadly Redemption
is it comes along very infrequently yeah
you have forms of redemption you're but
it's never you're never whole it's like
I wish I had listened to my elders
cuz your parents my parents but some
parents would give you all the keys to
life like we would tell you don't do
that right and you go H it's different
Our Generation and it's like and I truly
believe that's Nature's Way of you
learning unfortunately you have to learn
your way you can't take my experience
yeah and live through it right it's a
different experience a different year
different time different music but we
want for our kids go don't stick your
hand in the fire it's going to burn goes
oh come on dad ouch God he was right
right well you can take that and magnify
it a thousand times and that's regret
that you didn't pay attention yeah do
you think you were able to purge a lot
of that regret when you finished Rock
E6 or do you think you still hold on to
a lot of the trauma
and it it comes and goes it it comes and
waves you know you think everything is
fine that's why uh you never really
purge yourself of memories you can sort
of you know play music loud and be
surrounded by hundreds of friends but
then the music goes and you're living in
a quiet room and you have that but you
just got to go that's part of life
regrets sadness discipline depression
it's all part of life they didn't give
you a handbook they should have told you
if I told you at 10 years old you're G
going to be miserable someday you're
going to be like God damn and then
you're going to be so happy you won't
even know why right wake up in the
morning some sometimes you wake up in
the morning you had a nice sleep and
you're in a bad mood yeah why right it's
I'm telling you it's so complex this
thing yeah yeah that you can only sort
of play games with it and and and manage
it go okay I'm never going to be happy
all the time deal with it right I'm
going to be jealous I'm going to be
envious it happens I always thought it
so interesting when you see the dead
seven deadly sins or the Ten
Commandments like don't do this and
don't do that it's because our natural
instinct is to do those things right
yeah it's like it's that's why they even
the wise men wrote it back then we have
this propensity to
do not such healthy things yeah yeah and
you go but that's the that's the
character of the brain that's why it's
so great to have a dog or whatever CU
they don't have those thoughts right
truly they're not that complex right
where did that conversation go well I
want to sort of tying into that you
always taught us growing up you always
said time is our greatest currency y it
is it is and um that's something I think
Sophia and I live by tremendously just
because of course cuz that's that's the
essence of survival if you blow your
currency can't get it back it isn't like
oh I could take a loan do I get an extra
10 years no well I'm going to follow
that with a very loaded question that's
going to be extremely difficult to
answer okay okay if if possible looking
back on your entire career as a whole
where do you think you wasted the most
time where does that regret
lie um
that's not complicated
oh when I started to re to rely upon
other people's works or suggestions from
certain advisors this is good for your
career this is that try this and try
that and you're trusting their
instincts and that's where you make your
mistakes because if if you don't feel it
like like I told you like you know when
I saw your mother or something was like
boom if you don't have it committed say
I love this this I would do this for
free and and I recommend every actor to
do this and every artist please learn
every aspect of your business first of
all the business of
business uh be a hyp in it learn to
direct try to learn to produce if you
don't even do it learn how to do it
because if you're just just a solitary
performer then you're always going to be
at
someone's behest they'll tell you what
to do yeah back call oh I got something
for you it or otherwise you just sit
there and you wait like like this
yeah please and and I found that to be
the the most important lesson is trying
to learn every aspect of this business
don't be so complacent think oh I'm just
going to be a one thing fer piano player
I want to be a 10 finger piano player
yeah it makes you stronger and it makes
you also more of a weapon and I know
that cinee and I we've definitely
learned that coming through the business
that we from you guys from you and Mom
that knowing all angles knowing every
single Corner F too it's interesting but
that also holds true for Life yeah yeah
I there was a
poem written and I think this it really
sums up my life
by Robert Frost it goes we all dance
around in a ring and
suppose but only the answer sits in the
middle of nose you're never going to get
to it you're going to go what is life
dancing around I suppose I think you
think you have a philos you have a
philos everyone has a different thing
but no one has what is life because
there's 8 billion people there's 8
billion different interpretations of
what life is MHM
right I mean am I depressing no no I
just I have I have one final question
and again no and I'm so sorry I think
honestly this interviewer is terrible no
no it's the opposite I was going to say
I wish we had three more hours to keep
going well no and I have to say no but I
have to say which which and this is
something that I think people were the
most shocked by watching this
documentary cuz I know cinee got this
from people I got this from people is
the fact that speaking of trying on hats
and knowing every single angle of your
industry is that you did it all you've
written you've you've directed you acted
they people really didn't understand
that you were a part of every
single you know angle of your work you
didn't just give it to someone you
created it and you are the Creator it is
it's remarkable and it's rare and I
think that that was something that we
were so proud to hear from people was
that they were crying cuz they didn't
realize you're you just very unexpected
they wer they weren't expecting you to
be so smart and so wise and so going off
of what you just mentioned
about lessons you're learning in life to
wrap up this incredible interview what's
one lesson that you can leave your
daughters today oh my God just A Life
Lesson from all your years of
learning I don't know it's
like the
lesson lies in
learning and then by teaching people
what you know you also be taught because
they'll tell you things so the lesson
lies in learning and by teaching you'll
be taught I know that's very ambiguous
but it's that's what it's all about not
thinking you know everything cuz how
boring would that life be you don't be
the smartest person saying that he who
said says he knows right mhm doesn't
doesn't know and he who says he doesn't
know knows that's so important I think I
know everything and I realize you know
nothing you know back to the drawing boy
that's why you know you see me always
looking for it like odd useless facts
but I find it fascinating yeah that I
don't know all these things don't lose
your curiosity yeah yeah Dad I said
never lose your curiosity said the cat
you truly are curious the cat we we love
you this is this totally exceeded our
expectations are you serious we're so
but also we're so proud of you this
documentary is beautiful is there
anything else you want us to ask you
before we wrap up is there anything that
in the documentary that was missing that
you want to discuss is there because we
can still we can do another five minutes
if there's something you want to
specifically be asked and we can add it
in I I just um I felt in the
documentary the pillows poking up oh the
pillow move your pillow a little bit
that way yeah
perfect it's fine how's that is that
okay it's better no it's it's all right
so yeah is there anything that
specifically you want um us to ask you
and we can input
it
I I wanted I I didn't
know all the things I thought I knew
about myself so watching the
documentary I think people have got to
realize
that they're not
alone that life is
incredibly
complex and a terrible
mystery it's the thing that can take you
the highest like
love love is the only
emotion that can take you to the highest
Pinnacles and drop you to Hell the only
emotion mhm in in the world and I found
that the
more love you try to give to other
people and stop being so hellbent on
persecuting yourself and feeling
Loveless it just makes you feel
God lighter better so I want you all to
kiss yourself tonight and be gentle on
that sweet pillow oh thank oh go we
definitely will but I hope you know you
are so
loved I would die for you girls we would
die for you and thank thank you thank
you for coming on our show today this is
an incredible opportunity and we were're
not Beyond we we wrote four how many
pages four five six pages of s I got the
exclusive from slly what okay well thank
you guys for tuning in we will see you
next Tuesday and check out Sly his
documentary on Netflix oh thank you
girls I love you so much and you too my
be bye bye guys